LUKE MENAND: That was great.
Dan Gilbert is an
incredibly talented writer.
A lot of the hard part is, as
he says, finding the voice,
who you are on the page.
That's what readers
want to encounter.
Mainly, I'm going to make some
comments that merely repeat
and underline what has
already been said because this
is all excellent advice.
One thing that Angela
said is important
is that as academics, we like
to read books about books.
But most people like to
read books about people.
It really is important to think
about the ideas that you're
writing about, and the material
that you're writing about,
in the context of human
beings because that's
what readers respond to.
In my view as an
historian, there's nothing
dumbing down about that.
Because it just is the
case that human beings
are part of the world of
art and ideas that we cover.
If we include that
in our story, we're
going to enrich it in
every possible way.
Secondly, also something that
Angela said and been repeated
is that also readers
like a story.
We're not trained to
do that, most of us
in our scholarly writing.
That's just not the way
a journal article reads.
But again, there's
nothing wrong with turning
what you have to
say into a narrative
because people like to follow
it in the form of a story.
Those are two things that
aren't the way we normally
would approach a subject
for an academic audience
but are important for a
more general audience.
The final thing is that people
are interested in people.
And people are
interested in stories.
But they're also
interested in you.
They want to get to
know you as a writer.
In my experience, I put
very little of myself
into my writing.
I'm very stingy about it.
I don't think it's really
about autobiography,
or confession, or anything.
It's about having a
personality in your writing
to make people want
to read more of it
and get to know you
a little bit better.
Malcolm Gladwell
is genius at that.
Adam Gopnik is great at that.
It's part of what you
need to do to put yourself
in front of readers.
They become interested in
you and fascinated by you.
And they want to read more
of what you're writing.
The second thing I wanted
to talk about a little bit
was this question
about the money.
I don't think any of
us want to write trade
books to make a lot of money.
Very, very few people
who write trade books
make significant
amount of money.
I wrote a book that was
called The Metaphysical
Club that was a bestseller.
It took me 10 years to write it.
If I amortized how much
money I made off that book,
it was not worth
10 years writing.
I didn't write it to make money.
I wrote it because I
wanted people to read it.
I'm sure that's
true of all of us.
The important thing is
that you're reaching people
and that you're spreading
what your knowledge is,
what your ideas are, to people
who normally wouldn't encounter
them.
One way to think about
that, for a long time
I used to work at The
New York Review of Books.
The way we thought
about writing there
was to think about writing an
article or review on a topic
that you knew a lot
about and thinking
of your reader as somebody in
another academic department who
knew nothing about that subject.
Your reader is
very well educated.
Your reader is probably
smarter than you are.
But your reader doesn't know
anything about the subject
that you're writing about.
That's a good target audience,
I think, for the kind of books
that we want to write.
Because we want people
who are intelligent,
educated, interested, but
ignorant of our subject.
If we can reach
those people, you
can often think about
that as a colleague
in a different department.
If you can reach
those people, you're
going to reach a
much larger audience.
This is the third point,
and it's a little connected
to what I just said.
The New Yorker has a
million subscribers.
If you write a book that
5% of those people buy,
you'll have a bestseller.
Who are those people?
Those people are smart people.
They're educated people.
They're intelligent people.
They're mostly doing something
else besides reading books
or doing the kind
of stuff that we do.
Those people are people
who don't know a lot
about what we know a ton about.
When we write about our
research in an academic venue,
we mostly want to appear smart.
And we appear
smart by not saying
things that are obvious to
other people in our field.
We have a very
complicated mechanism
for sorting out things
that might sound
banal or apparent
to people who are
our peers, our scholarly peers.
That doesn't work at all
in the non-academic world
because you're
dealing with people
who don't know a whole lot
about what you're writing about.
Things that are obvious to us
are not obvious at all to them.
They need to be told.
But they need to feel smart.
It's a very important
part of getting
readers interested
in what you're doing
is it makes them
feel intelligent.
You have to devise,
and this is, I
think, the trick for writing
for a place like The New
Yorker or The New
York Review of Books,
you have to devise a
way of saying things
that are completely
obvious in a manner that
doesn't make it seem as though
you're talking down to people.
If you write a sentence in the
sort of standard magazine style
and say something like,
Charles Sanders Peirce
comma the 19th century
American philosopher comma,
that's talking down to people.
Because you're
assuming that they
don't have any idea
who Charles Peirce was.
But you don't want
to assume that.
You want to make them feel they
had heard of Charles Peirce
and they know who
Charles Peirce is.
So you say, like
many 19th century
American philosophers comma
Charles Peirce had a beard.
OK?
Then they think, oh, yeah,
I knew he was a 19th century
American philosopher.
It's not that you're not
explaining everything.
You're explaining everything in
a way that sounds by the way.
You don't have to
explain the obvious.
But you do, you just
have to insert it
in a way that makes people
feel good about their reading.
Everything else that these
people up here have said
is great advice.
I think maybe the best
thing for us to do
is just try to answer
some of your questions.